sébastien est ce qu'il a réussi le test
de chef de parti est ce qu'il a réussi
cette première impression qui est
tellement importante je pense qu'on peut
dire que oui on nous la présenter
monsieur péladeau dans la course à la
direction du parti québécois parfois
comme étant m intempestives comme ayant
la mèche courte obnubilé par la
souveraineté et oups aujourd'hui il
arrive et il parle d'économie en ayant
une main tendue plutôt qu'un poing en
l'air à l'égard de philippe couillard
alors il a eu aujourd'hui l'élévation le
calme qu'on attend du chef de
l'opposition officielle qu'on attend en
fait d'à peu près tous nos politiciens à
la période de questions et c'est il
avait beau jeu dans la mesure où en
faisant cette proposition de sommet
économique il ne se mettait pas trop en
danger il savait que philippe couillard
allé lui dire non parce qu'après un
premier ministre qui accepteraient ce
genre de proposition d'un chef de
l'opposition officielle mais il nous a
un peu surpris parce qu'il va labourer
les plates bandes du parti libéral et de
la coalition avenir québec en parlant
d'économie il donne ainsi le ton à son
mandat de chef de l'opposition
officielle et de chef du parti québécois
ainsi que les attentes étaient élevées
en même temps bas c'était un peu
prévisible il a dû répondre à des
questions sur son contrôle de quebecor
oui quand il s'est levé ce matin
monsieur péladeau et qu'il a enfilé ses
souliers de chef de l'opposition
officielle il savait pas qu'il avait un
petit caillou à l'intérieur qui était la
vente d'archambault par quebecor au
groupe renaud bray et ça illustre
parfaitement la situation délicate dans
laquelle monsieur péladeau est placé
dans la mesure où il reste actionnaire
de contrôle de quebecor ya des questions
qui lui ont été posées sur le fait qu'il
ait été ou non consultés sur la vente
d'art chambaud il n'a pas répondu
clairement à cette question l'un des
sources officielles au parti québécois
disent qu'il n'a pas été consulté mais
c'est un petit caillou dans son soulier
et tant qu'il ne régularisera pas sa
situation qui passera pas ses actifs
dans une fiducie sans droit de regard
mais peut-être même après aussi ça
restera un enjeu politique
un angle politique sur lequel ses
adversaires vont pouvoir l'attaquer donc
il ne vendra pas ses actions de quebecor
je vous dis pas qu'il doit vendre ses
actions de quebecor je vous dit
certainement que la situation actuelle
représente un caillou dans le soulier
pour mes supérieurs alors demain on
verra sa deuxième journée vous suivrez
sans qu'on le doit merci beaucoup c'est
bastien